Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Sol de la luz
fue vestigio de Dios.
Suelen anidar la verdad y el sol.
Y esta es la raíz donde el hombre crece.
Solo parará su dolor
con un gran padre de Dios.
Tengo en la voz
un pueblo libre que espera.
Sobre las heridas que hostigan la tierra
y en mi corazón de justicia y pena
como un sueño,
fundar la luz de un nuevo sol.
Y en mi corazón de justicia y pena,
como un sueño,
fundar la luz de un nuevo sol.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias.
Si trabaja el presidente,
mira cómo está la gente.
Si trabajan los obreros
pero no tienen dinero,
Si trabaja el campesino
y ser pobre es su destino,
Si trabaja mi papá y no le alcanza pa' na',
Ae, ae, yo no vuelvo a trabajar.
Para qué matarse tanto
si al final no queda na'.
Ae, ae, ae, yo no vuelvo...
Ae, ae, yo no vuelvo a trabajar.
Si trabaja el militar,
solo sirve pa' matar.
Si trabaja el carcelero
pero el mismo es prisionero,
Si trabaja el inmigrante
gana más un traficante.
Si trabaja el congresista
no hay pueblo que lo resista.
Ae, ae, yo no vuelvo a trabajar.
Para qué matarse tanto
si al final no queda na'.
Ae, ae, ae, yo no vuelvo...
Ae, ae, yo no vuelvo a trabajar.
Para qué matarse tanto
si al final no queda na'.
Ae, ae, ae, yo no vuelvo...
Ae, ae, yo no vuelvo a trabajar.
Para qué matarse tanto
si al final no queda na'.
Ae, ae, ae, yo no vuelvo...
Ae, ae, yo no vuelvo a trabajar.
(Palmas)
A ver si cantamos...
Ae, ae, yo no vuelvo a trabajar.
Ae, ae, ae, yo no vuelvo...
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias.
Taquita, tacatimi.
Taquita, taca-tá.
Quién te ha dicho que me he muerto
cuando perdido he andado.
Triste vengo, se alegremo'.
Quién habrá sido el doliente
que de mí se habrá acordado.
Triste vengo, se alegremo'.
Ya me estoy volviendo viejo
a causa del tiempo tirano.
No quiero volverme joven
como se vuelve el verano.
(Off) ¿Qué somos los argentinos?
(Voces en off)
Una cosa se me ha puesto
y otra se me anda poniendo.
Dejar la negra que tengo
por otra que ando queriendo.
Triste vengo, se alegremo'.
Se alegremo'.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias.